[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here
and we have some google pixel 2
rumors and at the risk of looking like a
rumors channel at least because like in
the last three videos there have been
two roundups but these are really good
so hear me out let's dive into them so
there's a couple big releases every year
that generate a lot of hype one of them
is the iphone boom you can watch my
iphone 8 rumor roundup video right there
that's everything we know so far about
the next iphone and also number two is
the google pixel the flagship from
google that spearheads android
previously nexus now pixel and this is
what we're hearing about so last year's
pixel or specifically the pixel xl was
one of my favorite phones released last
year possibly the best phone released in
2016. i kind of set it in the title
stock android fast updates to android
great performance great battery life and
possibly the best camera in any
smartphone even still right now but now
the rumors are swirling for google pixel
2. how does google follow up a super
solid phone like that and the first
pixel ever with an even better one and i
actually kind of said in one of my
recent q a videos on my wish list for
pixel 2 it would be mostly just better
more modern hardware the software
experience is already great stock
android is going to do its thing and
it's going to get stock android but you
could use a little bit more modern
pretty hardware well the leaks are
starting to pour in now and from android
police android police has a great track
record as far as android leaks and
smartphones go over the past couple
years so i'll link the full post below
but this is what they say we're getting
with the new pixel 2 xl made by lg also
keep in mind that logo the android
police logo as good as it looks is not
part of the design of the phone it's
just a watermark so yeah that's what
we're looking at pretty hot looking
phone looks like it'll have a pretty
similar overall look and feel to the
first pixel which is fine it obviously
has those characteristics but there are
some key differences so first thing
we're noticing here is that display it's
of course much bigger much thinner
bezels on the sides and top and bottom
and they're saying it's a six inch full
amoled display so that's dope and
they're saying we're also gonna get
according to android police a two by one
aspect ratio to enable that so the same
aspect ratio as the lg g6 display same
rounded corners as the lg g6 display and
of course an ammo led but i want to
throw caveat into this a two by one
display here it looks great and it looks
super clean and modern but i don't know
if a two by one aspect ratio on the
pixel the flagship android development
phone
is a good idea i could be overreacting
about scaling or about development and
maybe it's not a big deal but it seems
like they could definitely still do here
a 16x9 high resolution display as well
sort of a toss up for me there but of
course still an ammo led still really
thin bezels still really hot it also has
those rounded corners like we said like
the g6 and you know not a big deal there
but a lot of people like that and then
the edges of the glass will also be
curved into the body which is always a
nice touch not quite full samsung with
the display glass like melting over the
sides but i'm pretty happy about this
new display that's kind of what i was
asking for and then the second big
change you'll notice is the camera on
the back or just the whole back in
general this is a much bigger camera cut
out than the previous pixel remember how
small that was it was completely flush
in the pixel and pixel xl looks like
pixel 2 has a camera looking a lot like
the nexus 7 when that came out so really
interesting i don't know if that
translates in any way to the camera
quality and there's still no rumors
about what sensor they may be using but
i am very optimistic for the camera
quality in the pixel 2 considering the
pixel now still has probably the best
camera in any smartphone i don't think
they could put the same exact camera in
and still get the same praise but if
it's an upgrade in any way it's going to
be an excellent camera something we've
seen in a lot of new smartphones with
the snapdragon 835 chip they can all
afford to do auto hdr on all the time
because that chip can handle multiple
exposures at once so hdr was great on
the pixel if it's on full time every
shot's gonna look great and then the
head turning rumor from that android
police leak is that the pixel 2 will
have a squeezable frame just like the
htc u11 now again i don't know if that's
a feature that they're adding just for
buyers or if that's something that they
really expect to see in a bunch of
android phones like from here on out
when i first saw it in the u11 and i
said this in my video i didn't really
expect it to catch on much at all but
that kind of throws a wrench into it now
that this is lg not htc and they're
planning on doing the same thing so
maybe it is kind of catching on but
let's just go with it let's say they
make it just as sensitive to multiple
pressure levels as the u11 maybe they'll
let us remap it to launch different
things like possibly launching the
camera and taking photos with it or
launching the google assistant kind of
makes sense but if you don't want to use
it at all if you bought this phone for
other reasons they should also allow you
to disable it and never have anything
react to you squeezing it but yeah it'll
be really interesting to see how google
handles the whole squeeze thing in the
software ideally i think they let us
remap it to whatever we want they seem
like the type to let us do that and not
lock it down to one function
bixby
but yeah i know it'll be interesting to
see now something else to keep an eye on
is the speakers the speaker grille you
can see on this leaked render look super
wide and i've heard rumors of a very
important front
dual stereo speaker system on the pixel
2 this year which would be great because
the speakers on last year's pixel were
probably its weakest component and then
a headphone jack
yeah crossing my fingers for that hoping
they do that usb type c is probably a
given that'll be there too and then the
fingerprint reader it's on the back
again so no fingerprint reader under the
glass like we're assuming may happen
with the next iphone again it's in that
video but that technology is super new
so they are going with the fingerprint
reader on the back again but you may
have noticed it's now outside of the
glass like it was inside the glass on
the original pixel so it's a little bit
higher up and that also means that glass
window is a little bit smaller which
also kind of guarantees again with a
metal body no wireless charging that's
something i've always noticed like
wireless charging and water resistance
those two things seem to be the most
polarizing features about new phones
some people really just couldn't care
less like yeah you know i never who even
uses wireless charging
it's like a bonus to have water
resistance but other people are like
super adamant like i will not buy a
phone that doesn't have waterproofing
and i just need wireless charging i
don't really feel that same way but let
me know where you stand on that also
keep in mind these are all pixel 2 xl
rumors so this is for the bigger version
of the phone it appears that the smaller
pixel 2 will be much more in line with
like a spec bump of what we have now
might have the thicker bezels as well
it'll have the updated speakers it'll
have the updated camera but don't expect
that edge to edge display but either way
i am looking forward to pixel 2 xl i
mentioned it on twitter the pixel was
one of my most used phones of last year
and we will be looking forward to this
for a while because the pixel didn't
actually come out until october 4th of
last year it's july now so there's gonna
be much more time much more rumors
between now and when we actually see the
new pixel but i think pixel 2 xl will
probably earn its spot in my pocket for
at least a little while so what do you
think would you pick up this phone if it
turns out to be accurate these leaks are
true let me know what you think thanks
for watching
talk to you guys very soon in the next
one peace
[Music]